faze clan is back in the news after a
cryptocurrency project
turned sour with many people criticizing
the org of potentially running
an illegal pump and dump scheme and
finessing
its fans as a result two members of faze
have been suspended
one has been fired and there could be
massive
consequences if this whole mess is
thoroughly investigated
oi it's that time again hit all the
buttons
so you never miss the new content send
the stories that you want to see here on
don't at me
to tips at the score.com you know what
it is back in early june multiple
members of faze clan
including kaye and his brother jarvis as
well as popular youtubers rice gum
and summer rae started hyping up a
cryptocurrency called
save the kids on social media you might
remember faze jarvis back when he was
permabanned from
fortnite after he made a youtube video
of himself
cheating for fun as far as
cryptocurrencies go
save the kids was touted as a charity
coin
one where a certain percentage of the
proceeds would
well go to a charity meant to help
kids my name's frasier my name is jarvis
i'm tico
i'm ricegum i'm nikon and i support save
the kids token save the kids token
save the kids token save the kids token
save the kids token
it turned out that this kids coin as
it's referred to as
was potentially one giant scam that
could be
highly illegal it was certainly sketchy
enough that faze k
got fired from the org while his brother
jarvis and another member nikan
were suspended over their involvement
with the project
on top of that there's allegations that
faze clan as an organization
knew all about this although they've
since denied those accusations
before i explain all of that though
let's talk about cryptocurrencies
i don't have 25 minutes to explain every
single
aspect of what the hell cryptocurrencies
are but
here's a brief rundown essentially
bitcoin which was invented back in 2008
as well as other cryptocurrencies
essentially
cut out the middleman when it comes to
financial transactions
namely our traditional banking system
think of it as a peer-to-peer
interaction
i send you bitcoin it's acknowledged and
validated that i have the funds to do so
by the blockchain system
and then you get the money very very
simply put
think of the blockchain system as the
infrastructure used to house
all of the transactions carried out by
cryptocurrencies
everyone and anyone can look at these
transactions at any
time if they want to it's basically like
a
digital ledger book on paper
cryptocurrencies allow you to access
your money 24
7. there's little to no transaction
costs
you don't have the headaches of dealing
with banks etc you get the point
now obviously things get a lot more
complicated very quickly but that should
do you for this
video in addition to the
cryptocurrencies that are considered the
most legitimate which are bitcoin and
ethereum
there's also something called
cryptocurrency alternatives or
crypto alts which is the [ __ ] you've
seen a
million influencers promote online
dogecoin
mooncoin and yes even something called
titcoin
these are the types of coins that are
riding the bitcoin
popularity wave a lot of them are memes
not to be taken seriously while others
are sketchy at best kidscoin definitely
falls into this
crypto alt category and all of the
popular people i just talked about were
named as
kids coin ambassadors and told their
fans to go
buy this coin when it went live on june
6. thousands of fans hopped into a
telegram [ __ ] phone call thing yeah
they got people excited then shortly
after it went live on june 6th
the price of kids coin plummeted and
immediately there was concern
that these influencers had duped their
fans by getting them to invest
in a project that was essentially a scam
the main accusation was that everyone
involved with promoting this
coin was running a pump and dump scheme
if you didn't know this is when someone
famous hypes or pumps up a certain stock
or in this case cryptocurrency that they
own shares of
then once the price of that stock or
coin rises
the people who promoted it sell off
their shares for a profit
and this drops the coins overall value
leaving everybody else to hold the bag
on something that's
now essentially worthless in a regulated
stock market this is highly illegal
since pump and dump schemes are often
predicated on a
hype man making grandiose statements
about the product or
you know just straight up lying about it
but in an unregulated market like crypto
where there's basically no rules you can
sort of do whatever you want which is
why these coins are so often the target
of these types of schemes
so essentially the accusation is that
these phase guys
rice gum summer rae etc pumped up this
kid's coin
before eventually selling off their
shares and dumping the overall price
and the fans well the fans paid the
price
seriously this thing is so common just
google
crypto pump and dump and you'll find a
million
articles telling you how not to get
caught up in one of these
to be clear these allegations are
exactly that
nothing has been proven to be illegal
yet and nobody is saying that these
people intentionally misled their
fans except for streamer destiny and
we'll get to that in a minute
after all of these allegations started
flooding in phase k
jarvis rice gum basically everyone
involved
started deleting their original tweets
promoting kidscoin
by this point the [ __ ] had fully hit the
fan
every pop culture related news outlet
was reporting on the potential scam
and youtubers coffeezilla and some
ordinary gamers
both released videos breaking down the
situation
i have spent like 30 minutes just
vetting this myself and have come to the
conclusion that this is something
that is holy [ __ ] unreliable it is
using
save the kids in order to create this
weird token that is so obviously pump
and dump that anybody
all right even with the worst eyesight
could have seen this [ __ ] coming
so how is it that these influencers with
actual marketing teams
actual teams themselves didn't come to
this conclusion and it seems like to an
extent some of them did
each video does a pretty thorough job
tracking where the funds
supposedly donated to the kidscoin
related charity
actually went according to coffeezilla
phase
k was paid in tokens to promote not just
kids coin but something called safe
galaxy token a few months ago as well
more than that coffeezilla asserts that
phase k
dumped all of his kids coin 24 hours
after the project launched it seems like
they're not premeditating
to sell everything phase k on the other
hand whose wallet we're looking at now
should be called phase rug actually what
i mean by that
is that he not only sold save the kids
instantly
he has a history of doing that to every
project or nearly every project
he gets involved in also all of the big
streamers had a take
from pokemane to hasan to
destiny who actually claimed that faze
clan as an
org knew exactly what was happening and
told them to sue him if they thought he
was lying about it
all of faze knew about this the entire
time uh you don't like it sue me
i know for a fact every [ __ ] in
this team
knows exactly what's happening so it's
funny for them to kick people out
and be like oh we have no idea [ __ ]
i guarantee you
that they're selling these [ __ ] uh
they're selling these deals to their
teams or whatever
and they'll be like oh listen man it's
cool all you do is you buy it and then
you sell immediately after
it's all good dude you'll make a ton of
money guarantee there's no way that like
they're just passing these deals off
like oh well i don't know man good luck
figure out how to do it then on june
27th
phase k publicly acknowledged the
scandal tweeting out
quote i want all of you to know that i
had no ill intent promoting any crypto
alt
coins i honestly and naively thought we
all had a chance to win
which just isn't the case i didn't vet
any of this with my team at phase
and i now know i should have end quote
from there he talked about how he loves
the crypto space and how irresponsible
this all was
but the most important thing to take
away from that thread is
this quote i didn't vet any of this with
my team
at phase end quote on july 1st it became
explicitly clear that phase k or nobody
else for that matter had run
anything by faze clan as an org because
they released a statement saying they
had nothing to do with this project
they had fired phase k as well as
suspended faze jarvis
nikan and tico quote we have made the
decision to remove k
from faze clan and have suspended jarvis
nikan and tico
until further notice faze clan had
absolutely no involvement with our
members activity in the cryptocurrency
space
and we strongly condemn their recent
behavior the trust and respect of our
fans
has been and always will be our number
one priority
end quote now it's worth noting that
faze banks one of the founders of faze
clan has come under fire recently
for promoting a different crypto alt
called bank social
which many are also calling a potential
scam
and similar to how kidscoin went just 24
hours after banks promoted the currency
and it hit its
peak the price of bank social
plummeted he's since denied all
allegations that he was ever involved in
a pump and dump scheme tweeting out on
twitter that he quote
wasn't a part of any of this end quote
then on july 6th
banks went so far as to say that he's
the one who called for k to be let go
and for jarvis nikan and tico to be
suspended
what do you think about all the phase
members being kicked out of phase for
the whole thing that speaking i made the
decision
honestly hey all jokes it's
this serious matter okay do you think
there's a chance they'll come back
i don't know man it's like the ball's in
their court you know what i'm saying
the funniest part to me about all of
these influencers tweeting out about
this kids coin
is the quote not financial advice
tacked on to the end of all of their
tweets as if that's going to stop
anyone from coming after them legally
guys
guys they said it wasn't financial
advice i guess
we can't do anything about it we just we
got to go home now
as of right now no legal action has been
announced and it's
unclear as to whether or not any legal
action
will be taken but if an investigation is
launched we'll be right here to tell you
about it
well let me tell you about the
cryptocurrency
i don't know what that was i don't know
what came over me i'm sorry i apologize
to the people of uh
the uk
oh [ __ ] me man whoo
whoo
colton's gonna [ __ ] roast me